day to day life for the average
Venezuelan is a struggle from the moment
you wake up to the moment you go to
sleep from waking up and trying to turn
the lights on to finding out that the
power went out overnight and then trying
to take your morning shower to find out
that you have no water at home then pain
for everything has become increasingly
complicated there's no cash Venezuela
finding itself without access to dollars
without access to banks without access
to avenues of finance even for their oil
came to the realization I guess that it
needed money and it needed to find a way
to get cash when most the world didn't
want to give them access to cash all
assets of Maduro subject to US
jurisdiction are frozen so now that US
sanctions have effectively cut off motus
access to a global financial network
Gold is the last lifeline that Melville
House reports claim the Maduro regime is
selling out the country's gold reserves
to ease the pressure of international
sanctions in the last couple of years on
the side and sort of in secret the
Venezuelans and the Turks started
setting up a pretty sophisticated web of
trade of food and gold between the two
countries
we're not sure who's winning from the
cell - what s gold but what's clear is
that the Venice woman people are losing
[Music]
my name is Michael Smith and I'm a
reporter for the project and
investigations team here at Bloomberg
News my name is Patricia Layla and I'm
Bloomberg Venezuela bureau chief and I
write about Venezuela's clandestine gold
sales
so the situation in Minnesota is really
bad and there's currently sort of two
worlds in - 101 world is for the people
who have access and two dollars and you
can probably afford to have a power
generator at home in case the power goes
out and you can probably have a water
tank installed for when there's
shortages of water now there's the
second world that's the world that the
vast majority of Venezuelans live in and
it's the world where you live in Bali
artists
there's shortages of food inflation runs
in the thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousand percent nobody
really knows which means your say your
savings have long been gone
[Music]
there's extreme levels of crime that
makes life extremely difficult for
anyone who's just sort of living there
you have a whole population that's
subdued by hunger and that's also under
the control of the government who's
become their sole provider people who
can't really think of an economic future
because they can't think beyond the day
that they're living Nikolas Maduro is a
firmer bus driver and a former union
leader Maduro came to power in 2013 when
Hugo Chavez died and he was basically
Chavez his hand-picked successor
outwardly their message was that they
wanted to spread the country's oil well
fairly among the poorest Venezuelans
and for a while they were able to win
oil prices were really high they
funneled much of that money through
social programs in Venezuela but they've
been heavily corrupted in so many
different ways and bungled and you know
missmiss applied that they've really
turned into something that has just had
an incredibly detrimental effect on the
people of Venezuela in many many
different ways and when oil prices
crashed the whole economy came crashing
down because when it's well it depends
on 95 percent of of its revenue on oil
how bad is it and is there any end in
sight it's terrible it's getting worse
basically Maduro is waging economic
warfare against his own people his own
country an abuse of power that started
with Chavez that allowed him to not just
change the country's constitution but
also fill the country's courts and the
electoral authority with people that
were loyal to him and that allowed the
country to completely eliminate any sort
of democratic institution Maduro has
given most of the government's control
to the military so the feeling is that
if Malouda Falls they fall so they they
have formed a bond through
money laundering fraud and all sorts of
illegal businesses a first shipment of
gold bars has arrived in Venezuela after
President Hugo Chavez recalled almost
all the countries foreign bullion
reserves from Western banks so in 2011
shortly after the US economic crisis and
the European debt crisis Chavez
basically used that as an excuse to have
about 11 billion worth of Venezuela's
gold repatriated from banks in North
America banks in Europe back to anise
whele he said that it was a measure to
safeguard against financial instability
around the world and that moved by
Chavez almost a decade ago it's what's
keeping Naruto selling gold nowadays
it's legal for Malouda to sell his gold
but what's happened is that after US
sanctions a lot of the buyers have been
spooked so what's happened is that
they've begun to sell the gold in
secrecy on Venezuela you did the tough
sanctions and you sent the aid but it
seems like Maduro is is no closer to
leaving we really haven't done the
really tough sanctions yet we can do the
tough sanctions and all options are open
we want Maduro to leave so that there
can be free and fair elections with the
ultimate goal of ensuring that there's
democracy and freedom in Venezuela the
US has imposed sanctions on Venezuela
more than a decade ago but they never
went farther than individual targeted
sanctions until 2017
since President President Trump took
office
they were just accelerated to cover
hundreds of people and companies and
government entities and that sort of
thing we have continued to expose the
corruption of Maduro and his cronies and
today's action ensures they can no
longer loot the assets of the Venezuelan
people US sanctions can be devastating
for the people and companies that are
targeted they're listed and targets of
sanctions you become a pariah in the
system of Commerce and finance unless
you're in a country
that will allow you to do business
despite US sanctions and that's what's
going on with Turkey let's get straight
to the breaking news overnight and
attempted coup leading to chaos death
and instability in Turkey in July of
2016 there was a coup attempt in Turkey
against the government president hurdle
on and it was a serious material threat
to the air21 government the u.s.
watching the sudden uprising with
concern if erawan felt isolated he
wasn't getting much support from anyone
in the world that day and one of the
first calls he got was from a
representative the Venezuelan government
who contacted the Turkish embassy in
Venezuela and said we're with you we
know what it's like to be a victim of a
coup attempt we're pretty sure the US
government must behind it some well and
we're with you and that could that
contact which went all the way up to the
president of Venezuela and the president
of Turkey was really sort of the seed
that that turned into a conduit for the
win of silence to get their gold out of
the country and to turn it into money oh
no Tony lado de Oro el dia de banco
central de Venezuela there's been a
tremendous trade of of gold tons and
tons and tons and tons of it that has
left Venezuela it's a lot of the
national reserve had been sold off he
still has this lifeline that's available
to him and that he's clearly been able
to get away with we've seen him do a
multitude of gold sales this year
despite the sanctions that are in place
so they realized that he still has a way
to prop up his regime and to stay in
power there's an estimated 80 tons left
of the central bank that's about 3.5
billion dollars worth
what's left right now it's only enough
for six more months of food subsidies
for Venice what has people
so if Venezuela runs out of gold we
don't really know what's going to happen
what we do know is that they are feeling
the pressure and they and this pressure
of knowing that gold can soon run out is
what's bringing them to negotiate with
the opposition to predict where things
are going in Venezuela is a dangerous
game in my experience you could always
find people saying oh this can't go on
any longer it's gonna collapse but I
think it's it's it's it's it's a very
complex crisis there and it's going to
be very difficult to find a solution
that really works quickly I think
[Music]
you
you